shocker e-cigarettes are bad for you so
put that in your pipe in smoke a new
study published in the New England
Journal of Medicine says that
e-cigarette vapor can harbour hidden
formaldehyde a known carcinogen at
levels up to 15 times greater than
regular cigarettes it has the potential
to distribute deeply into the lungs and
collect their all right so last time
that Kara was on the show we talked
about e-cigarettes we're gonna annotate
to it right here and there's a link down
below to the segment and you were
talking about some of the health
problems related to e-cigarettes and
people were going bananas on you in the
comments mostly ecig smokers saying that
there are no health problems but Wow
more science just a couple months later
yeah I mean granted I don't want to I
don't want to say that I didn't maybe
speak a little out of turn cuz I think
the quote was something like they are
just as bad for you as regular
cigarettes which the truth is the jury's
still out
I was speaking more in the context of
they're just as addictive as regular
cigarettes they're just as bad for you
when it comes to your you know nicotine
habit as regular cigarettes but yes it
seems like every time a new study comes
out about e-cigarettes it just
reinforces the fact that guys this is
not a panacea there's just no way to
smoke in a healthy way
we wish there were which is why you
should be having edibles when it comes
to we've exactly you want to get rice
krispies treat right it's so funny that
people just want to feel good about this
horrible habit that they have it's like
if I just slap some quinoa on this
Baconator are the reason won't clog is
fast or I won't feel as bad to me
because I could pain while today I don't
think you leave out the other part but I
mean you're smoking at the end of the
day you're smoking tobacco and you know
you got formaldehyde yeah like that must
make you feel great yeah why do you
think people are so defensive about this
because I really did think it was
interesting in the comments on that
video that we did and again you said you
weren't an expert in this particular
thing but people were took it so
personally
and I guess it's to your point like
people just want to believe that
something could actually be okay with
you I feel similar to like religion
where you like if someone tells you what
you believe is not you've held on to
this and you've been do
for years decades and someone told you
that's not good for you that's not sure
that's gonna kill you and you're like no
if I find one sliver of evidence I said
this is possibly better or good for me
I'm not giving it up that's it so you
think it's like some kind of cognitive
dissonance that they have to have to
smoke because it's killing you and you
know it or you have to because the truth
is like when you when you talk about it
a typical pack of cigarettes you know
we're seeing legislation passed all over
the world that have you know cancer its
mouths pictures of cancerous mouths and
cancers lungs on the pack of cigarettes
this will kill you in all capital
letters no branding anymore no cute
little cartoon camel and people look at
that goes [ __ ] it I'm just too addicted
it doesn't matter in granted I can't
speak about this I smoked two cigarettes
for years and it was very hard for me to
quit but the last thing I would want to
do after I quit smoking cigarettes is to
pick up an e-cigarette and start the
habit all over again that sounds so
scary to me granted I think another
thing is people are defensive because
some people actually do use e-cigarettes
to quit smoking and one thing I didn't
like about the article is that it
basically just blew that like it was
like yeah that it's never gonna work
it's not good for you because it assumed
that the people who are using it as a
smoking cessation tool are smoking
e-cigarettes that have the same quantity
of tobacco as a regular nicotine
cigarette right but back when I quit
smoking this was before you've ached are
you old enough to say back when I go now
this was before vaping it was before
these like douchey looking cigarettes
and before you would drive down the
street and it's like vape store I had to
order it online from this website that
looked like it was made by an
eight-year-old and and they were they
look like cigarettes and the white part
was a battery in the little brown part
like the filter was the cartridge and
what you would do is you would order a
pack that it was a step-down pack the
cartridge would start at full nicotine
and it would step down to no nicotine by
the time you were done with it I don't
think people are doing that with these
vape ecig arrests I think they're just
yeah I wish you could have done this
whole thing in grandma's trying to do
can you just do the end of it in
grandma's well oh that's actually not
good oh that was all right it's a I'm
gonna try it again I'm gonna join again
don't smoke on my law
not good for you nothing highly highly
addictive don't start with an
e-cigarette you don't be like Jenny
McCarthy okay so that's that's how so
that's how I want to wrap this thing up
so Jenny McCarthy has been doing
commercials for e-cigarettes at least
was up until I haven't seen in the last
no but we great scientists right yes yes
she also is against vaccine people what
do you make of her play in this like
she'll take money knowing at worst case
scenario she knows the science is out on
the ESA's right thing she had no problem
taking money from them at the same time
the science basically proves you're so
right she's like we need more testing on
these vaccines they run for Congress
because that's a congressman stands by
the way she [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
oh really what do you make of someone
like that that can be like so outspoken
on one thing related to science and then
on the other hand just completely
dismiss it come in I think he's going to
just how [ __ ] her whole thing is or
it's like you have doctors and all these
like associations telling you vaccines
don't cause autism vaccines don't cause
autism now every kid in California is
getting the measles because she's on TV
we're listening to the Playboy model
tell us that we don't back send your
kids but she's on she's like taking
money to tell you like each cigarettes
are good for you they're better for you
when every 15 tot who's more from out
out Ginny's like no no it's fine and
then she takes the check and runs like
come on everybody's got a price I guess
do the thing that kills you do the thing
the killer don't do the thing that kills
your kids to quote Trayvon don't take
advice from former Playboy